[Müzik]
gençler Merhaba fizik bilimine girişin
ikinci videosundayız bugünkü derste
fiziksel nicelikleri sınıflandıracağız
fiziksel nicelik denilince aklımıza
fiziksel kavramlar gelecek Yani birisi
size fizik dersi dediğinde aklınıza
neler geliyor kuvvet geliyor hız geliyor
sürat geliyor ivme Momentum enerji bu
gibi kavramlar geliyor bunlar fizikte
büyüklük olarak nicelik olarak
isimlendiriliyorlar bunu niceliklerden
binlercesi olduğu için bunları
sınıflandırmamız gruplara ayırmamız
gerekiyor iki türlü gruplandırıyoruz
gençler temel büyüklükler türetilmiş
büyüklükler olarak Ayrıca skaler
Büyüklükler vektörel Büyüklükler olarak
ilk bakacağımız şey temel büyüklükler
olacak temel büyüklükten kastımız nedir
temel ne anlama gelir bir şeyin en küçük
yapı taşıdır her şey onlarla
oluşturursunuz Örneğin bir binanın en
küçük yapı taşı tuğla olarak
düşünülebilir bütün tuğlalar bir araya
gelerek bir binayı bir yapıyı
oluştururlar yani temellerden Biz başka
şeyler türetiriz genel mantık bu olmakla
beraber burada sayacağımız büyüklüklerin
bir böyle olduğunu da unutmamamız
gerekiyor dünyanın her yerinden
fizikçiler oturmuşlar ve temel
büyüklükler olarak burada sayacağımız
büyüklükleri belirlemişler niye bunu
söylüyorum Çünkü bazı Büyüklükler kafa
karıştırıcı olacak Hocam siz bunu
söylediniz ama onun daha temel versiyonu
var diyeceksiniz bana bu söylediklerimin
birer kabul olduğu orada aklınıza gelsin
bunları ismen Bileceksiniz kütle Işık
şiddeti sıcaklık akım şiddeti madde
miktarı uzunluk ve zaman neden bunları
ismen bilmeniz gerekiyor Bakın size 7
tane büyüklük Saydım fizikte bunlardan
yüzlercesi binlercesi var oturup hepsini
ezberleyemeyeceğinize göre şöyle bir
akıl yürütme yapacaksınız Temeller
bunlarsa geri kalan her şey aklınıza
gelen bütün fiziksel Büyüklükler
türetilmiş büyüklüktür diyeceksiniz O
yüzden sadece temelleri bilmeniz
soruları çözmenizde size yardımcı olacak
bunları nasıl öğrenebilirsiniz Baş
harflerinden öğrenebilirsiniz kısa muz
olarak kodlayabilirsiniz bunları
zihninizde her bir harfin hangi
büyüklüğe karşılık geldiğini
Bileceksiniz şimdi buradaki tabloda
Sembol görüyorsunuz birim görüyorsunuz
hangi ölçme aracıyla ölçüleceğini
görüyorsunuz hepsini bu derste oturup ez
fizikte zaten konuları öğrendikçe Bunlar
tekrar tekrar karşınıza gelecek ve zaman
içerisinde öğrenmiş olacaksınız bu
derste oturup da bu tabloyu ezberlemeyin
kütleyi m harfi ile gösteriyorum birimi
Sai birim sisteminde kilogramdır sa
birim sistemi önemli bizim için
uluslararası standartlar anlamına
geliyor fransızcadaki Baş harflerinden
geliyor yine bilim insanları oturmuşlar
her bir büyüklüğe bir birim atamışlar ve
bilimsel çalışmalarda biz bunları
kullanalım demişler Örneğin kütle
dediğiniz şey İlla kilogramla tarif
etmek zorunda değilsiniz Biz günlük
hayatta gram da kullanırız günlük
hayatta ton da kullanırız önceki
dersimizde öğrenmiştik ama bilimsel bir
çalışma yazıyorsanız bütün dünyada
geçerli olacak bir şeyse orada
kullanmanız gereken birim Eser birim
sistemindeki kilogramdır hepsini tek tek
söylemeyeceğim dediğim gibi konular
ilerledikçe Zaten öğreneceksiniz bazı
kafa karıştırıcıları öğrenmelisiniz
sorularda size vurdukları yerleri
öğrenmelisiniz Örneğin sıcaklık
sıcaklığın birimi günlük hayatta çokça
kullandığımız selsiyus değildir el Say
birim sisteminden bahsediyorum nedir
kelvin'dir gençler günlük hayatta hava
kaç derece dediğinizde 27 santigrat
derece deyip Aslında Siz şunu tarif
ediyorsunuz ama bilimsel bir çalışmada
celsius gibi bir birimin oluşturduğu
bazı problemlerden dolayı Kelvin
kullanırız bir başka dikkat etmemiz
gereken şey akım şiddeti i harfiyle
gösterilir birimi amperdir biriminin
sembolü de A harfidir şimdi akım
konusunu öğrendiğinizde şunu
yazacaksınız akım denilen şey Bir telin
kesitinden Birim zamanda geçen yük
miktarıdır birim zamandaki yük miktarı
dediğimizde akım kavramını bulmuş
oluyoruz Dolayısıyla elektrik akımı
kavramıyla yük kavramlarını
düşündüğümüzde sanki yük daha temel bir
şeymiş gibi düşünülüyor hocam buraya
akım değil de yük yazmamız gerekmez mi
diye düşünüyorsunuz Hayır buraya yük
yazmamız gerekmiyor gençler Çünkü başta
söylediğim şeye geliyoruz Bunlar birer
kabul akım şiddeti temel büyüklük olarak
kabul edilmiştir Dolayısıyla yük
dediğimiz büyüklük fizikte türetilmiş
bir büyüklük olarak geçer Bu tablo ile
ilgili son söylemem gereken şey de
öğrencilerin bir kısmında olan yine bir
yanılgı atıyorum öğrenciye kütle diyoruz
temel büyüklük olduğunu biliyor bunu
sembolü nedir dediğimde hocam
kilogramdır diyor Hayır bunun sembolü
kilogram değil biriminin sembolü
kilogram sembolü M harfidir gençler
ingilizcesinden geliyor buradaki
büyüklük sembolleri zaten ya
ingilizcesinden Ya fransızcasının baş
harflerinden geliyor işte zamanın Time
olmasından aklınıza gelebilir temel
büyüklükleri öğrendiyseniz dediğim gibi
geri kalan aklınıza gelen bütün fiziksel
kavramlar türetilmiştir kısa muzu
bilmeniz O yüzden yeterli olacaktır
kuvvet sürat enerji basınç elektrik yükü
nokta nokta yani bunları
çoğaltabilirsiniz yüzlercesini
yazabilirsiniz Bunların hepsi türetilmiş
büyüklüktür hocam bunlara niye
türetilmiş diyoruz Çünkü türetiliyorlar
neden türetiliyorlar temellerden
türetiliyorlar Örneğin sürat kavramına
bakalım sürat dediğimiz şey yine
ortaokuldan bilebilirsiniz ya da zaten
İlerleyen derslerde öğreneceksiniz Birim
zamanda alınan yoldur bunu nasıl tarif
ederiz bunu şöyle tarif edebiliriz Birim
zamanda ki alınan yol ona da x de
gösterirsem x bölü T1 biz buna sürat
diyoruz şimdi alınan yol dediğim şey ne
uzunluk ölü te yani zaman uzunluk temel
büyüklük zaman temel büyüklük Bu ikisini
kullanarak iki temel büyük kullanarak
Biz sürat kavramını türetmiş oluyoruz o
yüzden türetilmiş büyüklük veya kuvvet
denilince aklımıza çok bilindik bir
formül gelir F = mayı düşünelim burada M
dediğim şey kütle a dediğim şey ivme
kütle temel bir büyüklük ivme türetilmiş
büyüklük İlla her şeyin temel olmasına
gerek yok Bunu da açabilirim Çünkü ivme
de metre bölü saniye karedir yani
uzunluk bölü saniye çarpı saniyedir
konusu geldiğinde öğrenirsiniz
Dolayısıyla kuvvet dediğim şey ne kütle
çarpı ivme yani kilogram çarpı metre
bölü saniye kare zaten tabloda birimin
açık hali olarak bu yazıyor gençler
kütlenin birimi Aslında bu ama biz buna
Newton'un fizikte yaptığı çalışmalardan
dolayı mesai birim sisteminde Newton
diyeceğiz konusu geldiğinde
öğreneceksiniz işte sürat V sembolü ile
gösterilir birimi metre bölü saniyedir
enerji e sembolü ile gösterilir birini
joulder basıncı p harfi ile gösteririz
vs bilim sisteminde birimi pascaldır
gibi gibi gibi bunları çoğaltabiliriz
bakın elektrik yükü burada özellikle var
türetilmiş bir büyüklük sakın temel
demeyin buna Daha önce de uyardığım gibi
akım dediğim Birim zamanda telden geçen
yük miktarı O zaman bu nasıl türetilmiş
oluyor Ben burada yükü çekersem akım
çarpı zaman olur yani burada İçler
dışlar çarpım yapmış oluyorsunuz akım
temel büyüklük zaman temel büyüklük
Dolayısıyla Biz burada ne yaptık biz
burada yükü türetmiş olduk kabul gereği
Bu Böyledir hemen bir uygulama yapalım
Bununla ilgili Aşağıdakilerin hangisinde
bir temel büyüklüğün ölçümü Sai birim
sistemi ile ifade edilmiştir Bakın bu
sorular çıkmış sorular Bu kadar basit
sorular gelebiliyor tyt'de bir araba
Ortalama bir buçuk tondur burada
kütleden bahsediyoruz ama ton Eser birim
sistemini kullandığımız bir kütle birimi
değil Dolayısıyla boşluk olmaz bir gün
24 saattir zamandan bahsediyoruz birim
sisteminde zamanın birimi saniye
olmayacaktır ses hızı hava ortamında
yaklaşık 330 metre bölü saniyedir metre
bölü saniye sa birim sistemine uygun E
hocam e mesai soruyordu zaten cevabımız
C hemen atlamamamız lazım Çünkü ne diyor
soruda soruyu iyi okumak lazım temel
büyüklüğünü ölçü mü diyor Evet metre
bölü saniye vesair birim sisteminde ama
ölçtüğümüz şey hız hız gençler
içerisinde yok türetilmiş Bir
büyüklüktür aynı sürat gibi metre bölü
saniyedir yani uzunluğu zamana bölerek
bulursunuz türetirsiniz yani o yüzden bu
şıkkımızda olmaz bugün hava sıcaklığı 24
celsius'tur sıcaklık belirtiyoruz eshay
birim sisteminde Kelvin kullanmalıyız
Ali'nin boyu 1.72 metredir metre
uzunluğun esairdeki birimidir doğru
boydan bahsediyoruz kısa muzun u'su yani
uzunluk temel bir büyüklük aradığımız
şık e şıkkıdır aşağıdaki ölçüm
aletlerinden hangisi türetilmiş bir
büyüklük ölçer yani Biz temellerin
haricini arıyoruz kısa muzun haricini
arıyoruz gençler termometre sıcaklık
ölçer termodan aklınıza gelsin önceki
videomuzda konuşmuştuk bunu Latince'de
ısı sıcaklık anlamlarına geliyor e
buradaki s harfi sıcaklığı temsil ediyor
Dolayısıyla temel bir büyüklük ölçüyor
fotometre fotodan aklınıza gelsin Işık
şiddeti ölçer Işık şiddeti buradaki ı
harfidir temel büyüklüktür ampermetre
amper akımın birimidir ampermetre Akım
ölçer Dolayısıyla akım buradaki a
harfidir temel büyüklüktür Kronometre
zaman
kelimesi zaten yine latincede zaman
anlamına geliyor buradaki Z harfidir
dinamometre gençler kuvvet ölçer böyle
içinde yay olan bir alettir o yayın
ucunda bir kanca vardır o Kanca bir
kuvvet uygularsınız yay uzar Ne kadar
çok kuvvet uygularsanız Yani o kadar çok
uzar yayın uzama miktarına bağlı olarak
ne kadar kuvvet olduğunu ölçmüş
olursunuz ne kadar çok uzuyorsa o kadar
çok kuvvet var dersiniz dinamometre bu
burada kuvvet var mı hocam k harfi var k
harfi neydi gençler k harfi kütledi
Sakın karıştırmayın kuvvet değil
Dolayısıyla dinamometre bir türetilmiş
büyüklüğü yani kuvveti ölçer fizikte
ivme birim zamandaki hız değişimi olarak
tanımlanırken bir cisme etki eden Net
kuvvet cismin kütlesi ile ivmesinin
çarpımına eşittir Bu cümle bana henüz
öğrenmediğiniz
e=maye tarif ediyor aslına bakarsanız
Buna göre Yukarıdaki büyüklükleri temel
ve türetilmiş olarak sınıflandırınız
bize eşleştirme
hangileri temel hangileri türetilmiş
diye soruyor yine şuraya kısa muzumuzu
yazalım buradaki F kuvvet demek Kısa
muzun içerisinde kuvvet yok Dolayısıyla
türetilmiş Bir büyüklüktür kütle
buradaki m harfi kısa muzun k'sı kütle
anlamına geliyor temel Bir büyüklüktür
ivme kısa muzun içerisinde yok
türetilmiş Bir büyüklüktür f=ma'nın
haricinde de Büyüklükler tarif edilmiş
burada zaman kelimesi var hız kelimesi
var zaman kısa muzun z'sidir temel
büyüklüktür kısa muzun içerisinde hız
yok Dolayısıyla hız türetilmiş
büyüklüktür büyüklükleri temel
türetilmiş olarak ayırdıktan sonra aynı
büyüklükleri farklı açıdan bir daha
sınıflandıracağız skaler vektörel olarak
ilk olarak bakacağımız şey skaler
Büyüklükler olacak şimdi fizikte bir
şeyin büyüklüğü dediğimizde aklımıza hep
sayılar gelir ama sayı tek başına yetmez
Örneğin 5 yazdım buraya bizim için
hiçbir şey ifade etmiyor matematikte bir
karşılığı var ama fizikte Şu an 5'in tek
başına hiçbir karşılığı yok o yüzden
Bunun yanına bizim bir şey daha yazmamız
lazım işte biz ona birim diyoruz kg
yazdığım zaman 5 kilogram dediğimiz
zaman siz diyorsunuz ki he kütleden
bahsediyor Peki ne kadarlık bir kütle 5
kilogramlık bir kütle Peki ben buraya
kilogram yazarsam ne diyorsun zihninde
Ne canlanıyor Aa kilogram diyor yine
kütle anlatıyor bana ama bu sefer 4 de
tarif etmiş yani 5'e göre daha az başka
bir şeye ihtiyacınız var mı kütleyi
tanımlamak için yok o zaman kütle nasıl
büyüklüktür kütle skaler büyüklüktür
Çünkü skaler büyüklük demek ne demek
bize bir ölçü değeri lazım 5 gibi 4 gibi
bir sayı lazım ama onun da ne ifade
ettiğini öğrenmemiz için bir de yanına
birim yazmamız lazım Dolayısıyla skaler
büyüklük bir sayı bir ölçüm sonucu ve
bir birimle ifade edilir zaman da böyle
bir şeydir dört Yazarım bir şey ifade
etmez yanına S koyarım 4 saniye yazarım
dersiniz ki zaman belirtiyor Sıcaklık 20
selsiyus yazdığında ya da evsel birim
sistemine uygun yazarsam sallıyorum yüz
Kelvin yazarsam başka bir şeye
ihtiyacınız yok skaler bir büyüklük olan
sıcaklığı tanımlamış olursunuz Bunlar
çoğaltılabilir hepsini tek tek
yazmayacağız konuları öğrendikçe onların
skaler mi vektörel mi olduğunu da
öğreneceksiniz şimdi çok basit bir
soruyla burada öğrenmeniz gereken bir
şey var kare şeklindeki arsanın bir
kenarı 80 metre ise çevresi kaç metredir
kare dediğimiz şeyin her yeri aynı uzun
sahip bir kenarında 80 metre varsa
burada da 80 var burada da 80 var burada
da 80 var çevresi demek ne demek
bunların hepsinin toplamı demek 4 tane
80'i toplarsanız 320 metre yapar Bu
sorunun cevabı budur burada önemli olan
şey 320'yi bulmamız değil Burada Önemli
olan şey Şunu fark etmemiz skaler
büyüklükleri direkt toplayabilirsiniz ya
da direkt çıkartabilirsiniz direkt
cebirsel işlem yapabilirsiniz elimde 5
litre süt vardı Bunun 3 litresi döküldü
o zaman elimde ne kadar kaldı dediğimde
2 litre kaldı hocam dersiniz direk
çıkartma işlemi yaparsınız Benim boyum
140 santimetreydi bu sene 5 santimetre
daha uzadım o zaman Benim boyum 145
santimetre oldu direkt toplayabilirim
Çünkü skaler büyüklük vektörel büyüklük
biraz daha farklı gençler Ne açıdan
farklı fizikteki bazı büyüklükleri sayı
ve birimle ifade etmemiz yetmiyor
Örneğin kuvvet Ben bir masaya 10
newtonluk bir kuvvet uyguladım hocam
şiddeti var ne kadar kuvvet uyguladım
onla orantılı bir şey birimine de Newton
dediğin anda onun kuvvet olduğunu
anladım ama yetmez niye yetmez Çünkü bu
kuvvetin farklı farklı etkileri olabilir
o masa üzerinde 10 newtonluk kuvveti sağ
tarafa doğru uygulamış olabilirsin masa
sağa doğru hareket edebilir veya 10
newtonluk kuvveti sola doğru uygulamış
olabilirsin masa sola doğru hareket
edebilir Bu ikisi farklı sonuçlardır
Dolayısıyla kuvvet gibi bir büyüklüğü
tarif etmek için bir sayı birim yetmez
Bir de ona ne eklemelisiniz yön
eklemelisiniz O yüzden vektörel büyüklük
dediğimiz şeylere yönde eklenmeli
büyüklük birim ve yön kuvvet vektörel
büyüklüktür hız vektörel büyüklüktür
ağırlık kendisi zaten bir kuvvet
demektir Aslında yer değiştirme Momentum
Bunların hepsi Bunlar Tabii ki
çoğaltılabilir vektörel büyüklüklerdir
burada önemli olan şey yön olduğu için
yönleri de nasıl tarif edebilirsiniz
Tabii ki oklarla tarif edebilirsiniz bir
vektör dediğimizde aklımıza bir ok
gelecek vektörün bir başlangıç noktası
vardır bir bitiş noktası vardır Bu ikisi
arasındaki mesafe yani vektörün uzunluğu
bana o fiziksel büyüklüğün şiddetini
verir büyüklüğünü verir ne demek
istiyorum on newtonluk bir kuvveti şöyle
bir vektörle temsil edersem 20 Newton
bir kuvveti Bunun iki katı olarak
çizmeniz gerekir 5 newtonluk kuvvetli
yarısı olarak çizmeniz gerekir Çünkü
vektörün uzunluğu o vektörün şiddeti
hakkında size bilgi verir bilmemiz
gereken bir şey daha var Genelde
kuvvetli kitaplarda gördüğünüzde f
harfiyle görürsünüz Üzerinde şöyle küçük
bir ok işareti görürsünüz Bu kuvvetin
vektörel büyüklük olduğunu tarif eder
Örneğin hız v harfiyle gösterilir V
sembolü ile gösterilir üzerine küçük bir
ok işareti çizilir Çünkü hız vektörel
Bir büyüklüktür bazı öğrenciler şöyle
zannediyor hocam kuvvetin üzerinde sağa
doğru Ok çizdiniz o zaman tarif
ettiğiniz kuvvet vektörü sağa doğru bir
vektördür Eğer tarif ettiğimiz kuvvet
vektörü sola doğru olsaydı kuvvetin
üzerine sola doğru bir vektör işaret
çizerdik Hayır böyle bir şey yok gençler
sizin vektörünüz nereyi gösterirse
göstersin üzerinde sağa doğru küçük bir
ok vardır Çünkü bu bir sembol o vektörü
nereyi gösterdiğini temsil etmiyor
sadece o büyüklüğün vektör olduğunu
temsil ediyor Şimdi geldik tyt'de
vektörlerle bize ne sorulabilir en
önemli yerlerden birisi Burası gençler
bakın Burada 4 tane vektör var a vektörü
B vektörü C vektörü C vektörü bunları
birbirleriyle kıyaslayacağız
karşılaştıracağız a vektörü ile C
vektörü arasında bir fark görebiliyor
musunuz göremiyorsunuz Ne açıdan
bakmalıyım hocam farka mesela iki
vektörün uzunluğu nedir 1 2 1 Bu da bir
iki birim O zaman bu vektörler aynı
büyüklükteler iki vektörde sağ tarafı
gösteriyor mu 2 vektörde sağ tarafı
gösteriyor yani yönleri de aynı
dolayısıyla doğrultuları da aynı
doğrultu ne demek a vektörü yatay
doğrultuda C vektörü de yatay doğrultuda
a vektör ile C vektörünün yönleri aynı
doğrultuları aynı Dolayısıyla
büyüklükleri de aynı o zaman ben a
vektörü eşittir C vektörü yazabilir
hocam B vektörü 4 birim dektörü de 4
birim Bunlar da eşittir yazılabilir mi
Yani şöyle yazabilir miyim B vektörü
eşittir dek vektörü Hayır yazamam çünkü
bir vektörü tanımlayan şey sadece
uzunluğu yani şiddeti değil vektör
denilen şeyin en önemli yerlerinden biri
de yönü B vektörü Kuzey yönünü
gösterirken D vektörü Batı yönünü
gösteriyor O zaman böyle bir eşitlik
yazılamaz B vektörü de dev vektöre eşit
değil bunların eşit olduğu tek taraf
büyüklükleri İkisi de dört bir O zaman
şöyle yazabilirsiniz bebektörü mutlak
değer eşittir dektörü mutlak değer
içerisinde Çünkü mutlak değer bize o
vektörün yönünden bağımsız sadece
şiddeti hakkında bilgi verir B vektörü
mutlak değer içerisinde ise bu aslında 4
sayısı demek Çünkü 4 birim uzunluğunda D
vektörü mutlak değer içerisinde ise bu
da 4 sayısı demek yönden bağımsız Çünkü
bu da 4 birim uzunluğunda mutlak değer
içerisinde bu iki vektörde birbirine
eşittir bazı kitaplarda bunu şöyle de
görebilirsiniz B harfi eşittir d harfi
bu da mutlak değer anlamına geliyor B
vektörü ile D vektörün üzerine ok
koymazsanız sadece B eşittir D
yazarsanız bu da B vektörünün büyüklüğü
ile de vektörünün büyüklüğü anlamına
geliyor aklınızda bulunsun Bu iki
gösterim aynı şeydir gençler peki burada
bir şey daha göstereceğim diyelim ki
şöyle bir vektör olsaydı sola doğru iki
birim uzunluğunda Bu da e vektörü olsun
e ile C ilişkisini nasıl yazarsınız bir
kere ikisi de iki birim olduğu için e
eşittir C yazabilirsiniz bu ne tarif
ediyor Şimdi öğrendik büyüklükleri eşit
veya ben bunu nasıl yazarım e vektörü
mutlak değer içerisinde eşittir C
vektörü mutlak değer içerisinde bu
yazılabilir Hocam ben sadece vektör
olarak yazmak istiyorum yani e vektörü
ile C vektörü arasındaki eşitliği nasıl
yazarım bunlardan birinin başına eksi
işareti koyarak yazabilirsiniz şu C
vektörü ise eksice bunun ters dönmüş
halidir O da zaten e'yi temsil eder İlla
böyle değil eksi e = c de yazabilirsiniz
Çünkü e buysa -e bunu ters dönmüş
versiyonudur yani c'dir eksi işareti
vektörü ters döndürür unutmayın buradan
yola çıkarak c ile D arasındaki ilişki
nasıl yazılır C vektörü ile D vektörünü
Ben eşleştirmek istiyorum eşitlemek
istiyorum şu an eşit değiller ne yönleri
aynı ne büyüklüklere aynı C kaç birim D
kaç birim 4 birim C'nin 2 katı D'ye eşit
ama yönler tutmuyor E o zaman bir de
başına bunu eksi koyarsam ne olur -2c
vektörü D vektörüne eşittir Bu C ise 2C
vektörü budur onun iki katıdır -2c
vektörü de bunun ters dönmüş
versiyonudur ki gördüğünüz gibi o da
D'ye eşittir gençler skaler büyüklükleri
direkt toplayabiliyordu cebirsel toplama
vektörel büyüklüklerin farkı biraz da
burada onları direkt toplayamazsınız
elimizde 10 n'luk kuvvet var bir de 40
newtonluk bir kuvvet var Hadi bu iki
kuvveti topla dediğinde cevap 50 Newton
olmak zorunda değil başka sonuçlar
çıkabilir Örneğin bir cismi dört
birimlik bir vektör etki ediyor 6
birimlik bir vektör etki ediyor Bunu
kuvvet gibi düşünürseniz 4 Newton 6
Newton derseniz bu iki kuvvetin toplamı
bu iki vektörün bileşkesi sol tarafa
doğru 10 newtonluk bir kuvvettir Siz bir
masayı çekiyorsunuz Siz dörtle
çekiyorsunuz arkadaşınız da sizinle aynı
yönde size yardımcı oluyor 6 ile Çekiyor
o zaman toplam etki nedir ikinizin
toplamıdır 10'dur Ama siz dörtle
çekiyorsunuz sola doğru arkadaşınız 6
ile çekiyor sağa doğru yani zıt
çekiyorsunuz bunların toplamı dediğinde
yine 10 mu dersiniz Hayır kim güçlüyse
onun tarafına doğru iki dersiniz yani Bu
ikisini çıkartırsınız 2 vektörün toplamı
her zaman cebirsel toplam anlamına
gelmez cebirsel olarak çıkartma işlemi
de yapabilirsiniz Tabii Biz şu an tek
boyutta uğraşıyoruz bunun 2 boyut
versiyonu Hatta 3 boyutlu versiyon da
var Onlar da ayetede birim karelere
ayrılmış düzlemde tanımlanan aynı
doğrultudaki a b c d vektörleri Hepsi
yatayda yani hepsi aynı doğrultudalar
şekildeki gibidir Buna göre
yargılarından hangileri doğrudur
denilmiş a vektörü ile b vektörünün
topladığınızda eksi B vektörünü
bulursunuz şimdi a vektörü sağ tarafa
doğru 2 birim b ve bekliyoruz sol tarafa
doğru 1 birim bu ikisinin toplamı sağ
tarafa doğru bir birim olacaktır bu a+b
vektörüdür bu sonuçla sağa doğru bir
birimlik vektörle b vektör arasında
nasıl bir ilişki var B vektörde bir
birim ama o sola doğru yani benim
sonucumla ters yönde O zaman bu arkadaş
neye eşitmiş eksi B imiş Dolayısıyla
birinci öncülüm Doğrudur gençler Çünkü B
sola doğru bir birimlik vektörse -b sağa
doğru bir birimlik vektördür ben de onu
buldum zaten dev vektörü ile c vektörünü
toplarsam b vektörünü bulurum bakın D
vektörü sağa doğru 3 birim D vektörü
sola doğru 2 birim masayı biriniz 3 ile
çekiyorsunuz sağa öbürü 2 ile çekiyor
sola masa nereye gider güçlü olanın
tarafına doğru
gider Dolayısıyla şu iki arkadaşın
toplamı sağ tarafa doğru bir birimlik
bir vektör olacaktır sonucum sağa doğru
bir çıktı bu B vektörü müdür B vektörü
sola doğru birdi sağa doğru 1 neydi
şuydu yani -bdi Dolayısıyla bu yanlış
bir öncüldür buraya ne yazması gerekirdi
eksi B vektörü yazması gerekirdi a
vektörünün şiddeti yani sadece uzunluğa
odaklanacaksın Niye Çünkü mutlak değer
için almış artı B vektörünün şiddeti
bakın Bunu direkt şöyle yazın hiç yönle
işimiz yok a vektörü kaç birim iki birim
o zaman buraya 2 yazacaksın B vektörü
kaç birim bir birim hiç yönle işim yok
buraya 1 Yazacağım 2 + 1 diyor kaç
çıkacak 3 çıkacak C vektörü de mutlak
değer içerisinde C'nin şiddeti 3 mü
bakıyorum 1 2 3 O zaman bu öncülüm
doğrudur mutlak değer varsa sadece
şiddette yani vektörün uzunluğuna
bakıyorum Sorumun cevabı 1 ve 3
olmalıdır Aşağıdakilerden hangisi
vektörel Bir büyüklüktür kütle skaler
Bir büyüklüktür 3 kilogram denildiğinde
bir tarif eksikliği tanım eksikliği
hissediyor musunuz kuzeye doğru 3
kilogram Batıya doğru 3 program gibi bir
şey var mı Yok skaler büyüklük hacim
skaler Bir büyüklüktür yönle bir işi
yoktur yani Elimde bir kalem var bunun
uzayda kapladığı yere hacim diyorum bunu
yönle bir alakası var mı hayır yok bu
kalem 20 santimetre küp hacmine sahipse
yönden bağımsız her yerde 20
santimetreküptür etkileri değişmez
elektrik akımı ve basınç en çok kafa
karıştıranlar oldukları için buraya
koydum İkisi de gençler skaler
büyüklüklerdir Neden bunlar kafa
karıştırıyor Örneğin elektrik akımı bir
telde şöyle çizilir işte 2 amperlik Bir
akım var denir okla çizdiğimiz için
vektör zannediliyor ama Elektrik
akımının tanımına baktığımız zaman
elektrik akımı dediğimiz şey bir telden
birin zamanda geçen yük miktarıdır Yani
bir miktardan bahsediyorum sadece bir
büyüklükten bir şiddetten bahsediyorum
Dolayısıyla elektrik akımı skaler Bir
büyüklüktür vektörel büyüklük değildir
basınç içinde aynı şey geçerli basıncın
tanımı yine konusu geldiğinde
öğreneceksiniz burada çok detaya Girmeme
Gerek yok birim yüzey alanındaki kuvvet
miktarıdır yine miktarla alakalı yönle
bir işimiz yok basınç skaler büyüklüktür
aklına yatmayanlar konu anlatım
videosunu izleyebilirler orada daha ikna
edici şekilde basıncı neden skaler
olduğunu anlatıyorum hız ise vektörel
Bir büyüklüktür üzerinde vektör işareti
vardır Çünkü hız aslına bakarsanız birim
zamandaki yer değiştirme vektörüdür
bakın cümleye dikkat edin yer değiştirme
vektörüdür Dolayısıyla hızda bir vektör
sorunun cevabı D şıkkıdır son kısmımız
bilimsel araştırma merkezleri olacak
Burada logolarını görüyorsunuz belli
başlı şeyler öğrenseniz yetersizin için
tarihçelerini falan öğrenmenize de gerek
yok Ne iş yaptıklarını bilseniz nasıl
bir yer olduklarını bilseniz hangi
ülkenin kimler paydaşı olduğunu bilseniz
yeterlidir TÜBİTAK herhalde duymayanınız
yoktur Türkiye bilimsel teknolojik
araştırmalar Kurumu Türkiye'deki bilimin
öncüsü kurum devlet kurumu tübitaktır
gençler Tübitak'ın belli başlı
laboratuvarları olsa da genel anlamda
TÜBİTAK dev bir laboratuvar değil
aklınıza bu gelmesin işlettiği
laboratuvarlar var Ders kitabında
geçiyor Gebze taraflarında yapılan
Marmara Araştırma Enstitüsü gibi yerler
var ama TÜBİTAK genel anlamda ne yapar
genelde burs verir mesela ben bir bilim
insanıyım bir araştırma yapacağım ama
paraya ihtiyacım var araştırmayı
yapabilmem için bana maddiyat lazım Ne
yapıyorum tübitak'a başvuruyorum projemi
beğenirse bana burs veriyor ne yapar
teşvik verir yani bilim insanları
araştırma yapsın diye Onlara ödüller
verir dediğim gibi parasal destek sağlar
ne yapar yarışmalar yapar işte lise
öğrencilerinin girdiği olimpiyat
yarışmaları var Ulusal Fizik
Olimpiyatları Matematik Olimpiyatları
gibi Dolayısıyla aslına bakarsanız Bu
bir Vergi Dairesi gibi bir devlet
dairesi Vergi Dairesi gibi parayı
almıyor tam tersine parayı veriyor ki
Türkiye'de bilim ilerlesin Aselsan
askeri Elektronik Sanayi yine bir devlet
kurumu İşte bunlar birer laboratuvar
gibi bir fabrika Bunlar askeri teknoloji
üretiyorlar zaten son dönemlerde oldukça
popüler helikopter üretiyor silah
üretiyor hangi üretiyor Türk ordusunun
ekipman mühimmat tedariğini sağlıyorlar
diyebiliriz genelde Türkiye'nin en iyi
mühendisleri aselsan'da çalışıyorlar
gençler kitaplarda çok rastlamadığınız
bir kurum Çünkü biz bunu Eskiden taek
diye anlatırdık yani Türkiye Atom
Enerjisi Kurumu diye anlatırdık bu
kapatıldı Yerine tenma kuruldu Türkiye
Enerji nükleer ve maden araştırma Kurumu
sizin
[Müzik]
etkisi yokmuş gibi gözükse de Cern
dediğimiz yerde Aslında internet
bulunmuştur ve bulunmuştur diyebiliriz
internet ne demek bir sürü bilgisayarın
birbirine bağlı olması Demek benim
bilgisayarındaki bilginin sizin
bilgisayarınıza da gözükebilmesi demek
Bunu ilk bulunduğu yer Cern Neden Çünkü
çok büyük bir yer binlerce araştırmacı
var ve bu araştırmacılar bir deney
sonucunu bir bilgisayardan başka bir
bilgisayara aktarabilmek istiyorlar ki
herkes görebilsin bütün bilgisayarları
birbirine bağlıyorlar Dolayısıyla
minyatür bir internet sistemi kurmuş
oluyorlar cern'de kendi içlerinde Peki
bu hangi ülkeye ait hiçbir ülkeye ait
değil bu Uluslararası bir kurum
neredeyse dünyanın her ülkesinden
araştırmacılar var milyarlarca dolarlık
bir projeden bahsediyoruz NASA bunu
söylememe gerek yok ulusal uzay Ajansı
ama kimin ulusal Ajansı ulusal deyince
aklınızda Türkiye'ye gelmesin Tabii ki
Amerika'nın uzay Ajansı gençler uzaya
uydu gönderiyorlar gezegenleri araçlar
gönderiyorlar biraz popüler bilim takip
ediyorsanız zaten bunlara bolca maruz
kalıyorsunuzdur en son James ve
teleskobundan gelen görüntüler meşhur
Kim gönderdi James NASA gönderdi ne
yapıyoruz uzayın Derin bakıyoruz bilmem
kaç milyar ışık yılı uzaktaki galaksiden
gelen ışığı inceliyoruz ki o koşulları
büyük patlamadan hemen sonraki koşulları
öğrenebilelim çok yüksek çözünürlüklü
fotoğraflar alıyoruz esa bunun Avrupa
versiyonu gençler european'dan geliyor
Avrupa Uzay Ajansı anlamına geliyor
nasa'ya göre çok daha küçük bütçeli de
olsa NASA'nın Avrupa versiyonu
diyebiliriz ve son olarak da Türkiye
uzay Ajansı var Bu da yeni kuruldu
kitaplar henüz girmedi daha emekleme
aşamasında bile değil ama bu da bir
başlangıçtır bir yerden başlamamız
gerekiyor ki uzayda söz sahibi
olabilirim Evet Böylece fizik bilimine
giriş burada bitmiş oluyor Bununla
ilgili Genel bir soru çözüm videosu da
yapacağız takıldıklarımızın Kendinize
iyi bakın görüşürüz
[Müzik]